what I was at doc gooden's no-hitter doc
gooden Zohan no-hitter May 1996 I'll
never forget because it was doctor
there's no hitter and in just a few
short months later if my life is gonna
change by the skull-fuck in the
prestress yeah because that was also 96
but the summer so so I'm sitting at the
game we're in the upper upper upper deck
which I'm fine with those seats sure my
dad's like you know Dwight Gooden its
seventh inning no hits my dad's like
this guy's pitching in no no I Kevin
kept saying my Dwight's pitching in no
no he kept saying Dwight guy's pitching
[ __ ] no no and then so and then so
he's like we gotta get better seats and
I was again but it's fine you know oh
and by the way that day what do I
couldn't snow hey there was a Monday I
had a science project due the next
morning the next day and my mother had
said my told my father specifically
leave after the fourth inning he needs
to be home we have to gonna wake him up
at 7 a.m. he needs to finish this
science project the fourth inning Tony
I'm serious now keep mine it's 1996 no
cell phones my mother's I get my dad's
again at a fourth inning I got it don't
worry baby call my mom babe still like
did been divorced 30 years but he still
calls her babe she's like this is
offensive so so he's like no problem
babe I'll have him back I'll see you
know gonna cook dinner she's like we've
been divorced for 20 years you know he
just doesn't get it he still thinks
we're happily married I'm like you live
in a bathtub so he goes so my dad this
is it so we're at the Yankee game now
it's the seventh inning it's [ __ ] way
past the fourth inning it's I see the
time like dad mom said to go home
because listen eat Dwight's pitching no
no
so she'll understand no yeah yeah sure
she'll understand she doesn't know what
baseball even is she's gonna know what
an Ono is so my mom so my dad goes all
right listen he goes it's coming up on
the eighth inning he goes we got to get
you behind home plate I gotta get you
behind home plate I said I hit but Dad I
don't care goes nana he's pitching it no
no we're gonna go because you gotta
listen to me do everything I tell you to
do this is all [ __ ] like in slow
motion I remember this day in my life so
we get down to the security guard behind
home plate and my dad sees two or three
open seats right behind home plate right
in the old Yankee Stadium and he says to
the security guard he's like he goes
listening goes uh it goes you know it's
Dwight's pitch in and no no he goes me
my kid I mean first time ever taken the
Yankee Stadium that was like my 12th
game that season who's like the first
time I've ever taken on his party game
name's a big mom for my kid Dwight's
bitchin oh there's two seats come on let
me just you know take it out cash my dad
takes out cash what do I need
you know greasing people and the guy
goes no he's not he can't sit down there
I'm sorry gonna have to watch him here
no man that takes your breath he goes he
goes all right he goes up but my son's
got special needs I was like what like
special needs and then I was just
sitting on with my mouth open like kind
of like with a half smile and then a
security guard gives me a noogie girls
have a good time kid Jamie a complex
because I'm like I know I have like a
weird mushroom haircut Supercuts but I
don't think I look like I [ __ ] have a
special needs well I swear to God where
the story gets unbelievable but I swear
to god this is [ __ ] true the row in
front of where me and my dad are saying
now it's a ninth-inning
Dwight's two outs away from the
no-hitter which he eventually yeah yeah
big deal he see I see I notice it's
[ __ ] I'm 12 years old
height of the double-double you have big
wrestling fan mr. perfect who is that
one row in front of us mr. [ __ ]
perfect the wrestler every kid's
favorite wrestler at that time
unlike dad that's mr. perfect and he
goes who's that and I go I go he's a
wrestler and he goes yeah I call I was
[ __ ] great and he goes and he just
trust yelling he he drops the mystery
goes yo perfect perfect he goes give my
son an autograph what about getting my
kid and watercraft likes but you did no
no and then mr. perfect I swear God
turns around he goes no I swear to god
he goes no like he was just and here
everyone is drinking and you know
whatever my dad does my son's got
special needs pass by mr. perfect and
then we get back and it was the same
story with my father as it [ __ ]
always is we're a block away from others
house two o'clock in the [ __ ] morning
down by 8:00 it's two o'clock in the
morning my dad goes don't tell your
mother what happened just don't tell
your mother what happened tell there was
a train delay a [ __ ] trailer so
literally I love your father do we rent
a great [ __ ] dad yeah we
wasn't great then write that and then my
dad is so funny because it's 2:00 a.m.
and my dad used to sleep in the basement
cuz he had to go all the way back to
Staten Island and then was 2 o'clock in
the morning and my dad starts walking in
to go to the basement and my mother goes
Tony get the [ __ ] out take the ferry and
three trains all the way back to its
houses memories special being special
and then and then yeah and then I think
I failed I didn't you know I got a deal
on that science project cuz I just
cleaned it worth it worth it what's new
I agree with you yeah that might be one
of my favorite stories and you didn't
think I'm kidding but I did it makes me
kind of think about how to parent my son
yeah I got to start doing these massive
two in the morning
yeah whatever like break oh yeah dude I
gotta take me to a game I've never taken
my kid to a [ __ ] game ah dude my dad
that would literally how you was force
for that was my dad's teaching places
for that anything like and it was always
rewards if I could get a good grade or
if I would you know clean my room or tie
up or my dad would be like the incentive
for you thank you a Knicks game I'll
take any Yankees game on thing you know
a New York Giants game so that and that
was all the moments with my father were
at stadiums great memories great moments
right mom yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]